OH MY GOD!
JOERGEN!!!!!!!
JOERGEN!!!!!!!!
RUN!!!!!!!
RUN JOERGEN!!!!!!!
RUUUN!!!!!
MOVE!!!!!!
MOVE!!!!!
Good Minecraft morning to you fellers!
TOP OF DA MORNING
Today, we are starting off the game
Outside
That’s because I downloaded
The PewDiePie Pack
(anime wow) That one of you fellow 9-year-olds have made
Another Super duper request is that i use shaders
and.. I have! and I've never seen it before
so this is the first time i am LOOKING at shaders in minecraft
Very epic
and as you can see here
it says minecraft JOERGEN edition
WhAt?
PeWdiEcRaFt
uhhhh yeah yeah yeah, hopefully, this doesn't break my save file
OOOH
wha a a at
-gasp- joergen you look so good
my god
oop-
wait i have extra gold oh gosh how'd this happen i was-
who the frick are you?
IMPOSTER
i can bearly see the water looks so pretty
my god
-hits- dont ever look at me again
daymn.. -ding ding-... this is weird
my god they're WIGGLING
they're wiggling
Joergen, Sven
let me look at you
oh mah gosh, you're cute UwU
-stares- you look the same
*MEATBALL LAUGH*
Joergen let me look at you!
Wow, look at how beautiful he is using that flare
My god
My god x2
So as you can see, there's a- Uh...
There's a couple of changes
I've been playing a lot, like a LOT, LOT
*Giggling*
I've been playing so much *laughs*
I didn't wanna get ahead, so-
I've just been-
...
Did that just move on it's own?
I've just been building stuff so
I build this tEmplE
For watersheep
It's a water temple
So there's water flowing everywhere
I spent a long time on this OkAy?
*Giggle* A very long time
Oh my gOd
It's for watersheep
Of course
Of course, I had to do it to him
And the idea is that the water flows from the water church
Into the-
It feeds
It feeds my crops
Thank you watersheep <3
You are gone but not forgotten
So, in this church
???
All the sheeps get to walk free
In the- uuhh...
...Where are they?
cOME BACK HERE!!
SCUMBAG
You're suppossed to be free!
Oh mY gOd
*laughin''*
*laughing* I think I found them
COME DOWN FROM THERE!!
*laughing*
how did this happen??
oh my god--
oh no, sorry!!
???
he just wants to go up again :/
NO HE'S ESCAPING, KILL HIM
why do I have 20 fps in here?
don't think so, cOwArD
be free
alright let me-- let me jump back into the regular one
that's cool! shaders is cool, okay?
don't get me wrong-- wait, I gotta restart the game
yeah, so, I don't know
shaders is cool and all--
no, don't you DARE even think about it
I'm trying to be nice to you, I built you this home :/
don't get me wrong
it's just that I've done 12 episodes, I don't wanna just change mid-way through
isn't that right?
sheep: baaa
that's right
um, I also built this minecart so that Sven can ride to his house :3
go in, Sven
...
ohmygod he has an armor, I didn't even think about it
get in, Sven
ikea bird: *barks*
oh my god
Felix, and Joergen 2, and Sven
that is SO cute >:0
*button* a-
oh my god
JOERGEN!
RUN!
RUN JOERGEN!
RUN!!!!!
MOVE!!
MOVE
*RELIEF*
MAKE A BUTTON THEY SAID
OH MY GOSH ARE YOU OK?
oh he's fine
this is such a dumb idea
come here joergen
*DAMAGE*
OH
*DRAMATIC MUSIC*
JOERGEN!
MOVE!
MOVE JOERGEN
oh
JOERGEN JOER- JOE- JO- JO- J
AAH
oh my god, oh my god, oh my god
Sven where are you going?
i'm so slow
GOOOOOOOOO
.
..
...
....
.....
......
.......
........
.........
..........
...........
............
.............
..............
...............
R.I.P JOERGEN
29/06/2019 - 24/07/2019
F